aux clayes-sous-bois cinq candidats
s'opposent pour devenir le maire de
cette commune de 17 1842 habitants lutte
ouvrière faire entendre le camp des
travailleurs investi huit candidats dans
les yvelines
parmi eux olivier augustin tête de liste
aux clayes-sous-bois c'est une troisième
candidature après 2008 et 2014
déjà menées à l'époque par olivier
augustin employé chez renault flins le
candidat souhaite faire entendre la voix
des travailleurs
à un moment donné bah oui il faudra que
on continue à se mobiliser qu'on
continue comme ce qui a été l'occasion
avec les gilet jaune puis avec les ehpad
puis avec les hospitaliers puis là
contre la réforme des retraites
eh bien il faudra continuer aux
clayes-sous-bois à se mobiliser pour
faire vraiment entendre notre notre
colère anne-claire frémont tête de lice
les clayes-sous-bois c'est vous et
sapeurs pompiers depuis 35 ans dans la
commune adjointe à l'éducation
parmi ces propositions la candidate
souhaite mettre en place un programme
d'adoption d'animaux domestiques par des
seigneurs isolé en partenariat avec les
refuges par un partenariat avec les
refuges alentours afin de permettre aux
personnes âgées d'adopter des animaux de
compagnie et du coup on prend isolément
et pour la personne âgée et pour
l'animal de compagnie autre candidat
nicolas huet de liste l'autre projet
pour les clayes-sous-bois le conseiller
municipal d'opposition souhaite
rassembler et faciliter les déplacements
des que les siennes et que les siens
nous souhaitons redonner une réelle
cohérence et un vrai
vivre ensemble à l'ensemble de la
commune notamment en développant des
circulations qui permettent aux
habitants de se rendre d'un d'un lieu à
l'autre et d'un quartier à un autre
quatrième candidate stéphanie jamin pour
la tête de liste énergie positive les
élections municipales se déroulent dans
un contexte d'urgence environnementale
dont son équipe en fait une priorité
la végétalisation des espaces publics ça
passe par les îlots de fraîcheur dans
les cours mais également des jardins
partagés récupérer l'espace public
également au niveau des bâtiments
publics il ya tout un travail à faire
sur les économies d'énergie faire un
audit énergétique tout simplement
enfin philippe dit guen ancien directeur
financier dans le secteur aéronautique
et de la défense
parmi les propositions de cet élu depuis
le candidat souhaite la création d'une
maison pluridisciplinaire de santé dans
le bâtiment de l'ancienne sécurité
sociale une maison plus rudes
pluridisciplinaire de santé qui est dit
pluridisciplinaire dit effectivement
médecins aussi bien généralistes que
spécialiste mais aussi paramédicaux au
niveau des médecins
je n'exclus pas même d'embaucher des
médecins au niveau de la municipalité